エアーブレード360
いつもお世話になってるおもちゃ屋さんで買わせていただきました
おば...
お姉さんいつもありがとうございます
買う時にお姉さんに言われましたよ
お姉さん）このおもちゃ YouTubeに出すの？
はじめ）多分...
お姉さん）楽しみにしてるね
はい
ありがとうございます
いつも行ってるおもちゃ屋さんのおば...お姉さんも見てるんで
ちょっと緊張してます
で、これなんですけど 何がすごいかって言うと
どう見てもあれですよ
ブーメランなんですよ
俺のイメージだとね
こうね投げると思ってたんすよ
投げるとそれを　投げるとそれがブルーンシュルルーン
HIKAKINさんになっちゃった
投げるとこうねそのままトバリングとかしてそれを操作できると思ったんですけども
違うみたいでラジコンらしいです
完全にこの餓鬼のせい
完全にコイツのこの手よ
これ紛らわしいよ
俺は完全に投げてそれを操作するかと思ったら
そうじゃなくてリモコンで操作するらしいです
これはいらん
まあでもどっちにしろブーメラン型のラジコンが出たということで
すごいっすよ
早速やってみましょう
立ったーーーーーー！！
＊パンチ＊
早速作っていきましょう
何がともあれ取り出しましょう
繊細な
うわ、これ怖ぇ大丈夫かな
こんな感じの本体ですね　めっちゃ軽い
ここだけプロペラがついてる
多分これでこう回転するんだと思います
で、これがコントロールです
wiiリモコン
完全にwiiリモコン
これで充電するのかな？
プラスドライバーを使って開けます
パーフェクト
OPEN THE PRICE
ok.単三電池×4
ごー！
（郷）ひろみ
これでつかないパターンがよくあるから
とりあえず確かめましょう
あ、付いてる付いてる
バッチリ点滅しております
これで多分動くんで
ちゃんとネジを閉じて
これ来たんじゃない？
もうもう来ます
ktkr
やばいやばいやばいやばいよ
これ力の加減だな
待って結構痛かったよ
これ多分なんですけど
充電してないからまだMAXじゃない
一回充電します
これ投げれるんじゃね？
うわー怖い
やべー血出っちゃった
it's not added like a dog well